VOICE OVER: ﻿Rubber is useful stuff.
And if you take some rubber, and
reinforce it with rigid particles,
you can make it stiffer -
which can be even more useful.
Things like tyres and belts and shock absorbers
all need stiff rubber that can resist deformation.
This material property is known
as a high elastic modulus - while
stretchier rubber would have a low modulus.
It’s easy to increase the elastic
modulus by adding rigid particles,
but what’s harder is stopping stiff
rubber cracking under repeated stress.
The ability of a material to resist cracks
under cyclical stress is known as its fatigue
threshold. And the fatigue threshold of
rubber has stayed the same for decades.
But now a team of researchers have
created a new type of rubber with
a fatigue threshold 10 times higher than before.
Traditional reinforced rubbers, or Particle
Reinforced Elastomers as they are known,
are made up of networks of rigid
particles and crosslinked polymers.
The crosslinks effectively weld
the polymer strands together
This makes the rubber stiffer,
but also more brittle.
The new rubber is a little different. It’s
still made of polymers and reinforced with
added rigid particles, but the polymers are
much longer with fewer crosslinks. Instead,
these long strands are entangled with one
another - like a bowl of spaghetti, with
the remaining crosslinks locking this structure
in place and stopping the polymers coming apart.
There’s a low friction between entangled
polymers which helps transmit any stress
across the entire polymer chain. The stress
can also be transmitted from the polymers to
the rigid particles and from one rigid
particle to another. All of which means
that stress is no longer concentrated on a
single point, such as the edge of a crack.
The combination of long polymer chains and rigid
particles work at different scales to amplify both
the elastic modulus, and the fatigue threshold.
And that gives you a material that’s stiff and
which can take more stress without cracks
forming or growing through multiple cycles
This development could have a huge impact for
manufacturing all sorts of existing products,
as well as in emerging fields like soft robotics.
The researchers hope that this study could
even lay the groundwork for rubber that never
wears out, opening an enormous space
for material design and applications.